uh there's been a lot of talk about the
nfl season
and when will there be an nfl season
will it be 16 games it'll be 14 will it
be 12 will it start on time one more
training can't be
there's also been plenty of talk about
college football season and big cat i've
been a believer that it's going to be
very difficult for college football to
proceed as scheduled for one very matter
a very fundamental reason
the people who run college football
still try to maintain the ruse
that
the players are student athletes
and if the campuses are shut down if
it's all online classes this fall which
i think there is a very good chance it
will continue to be
how can you let the athletes
into campus when the students aren't
there you're admitting to the world that
these guys are just pieces of a billion
dollar machine they're really not there
to be students with sports as part of
the extracurricular activity that makes
them well-rounded not that anyone
outside of that college
bubble believes it
but they still want us to kind of think
that they believe it so
i've been a believer that they can't
play college football this fall unless
all the campuses are open
and if they have to wait until the
campuses are open maybe they have to
wait until the spring and that was the
idea that chris fowler of espn put out
there yesterday he says it's gaining
momentum that college football 2020
could be played
from february to may
of
2021 which my first thought was i fell
out of the chair but then once you start
thinking about it it actually makes some
sense
okay so how does it make sense because
the one part i can't wrap my head around
and stats actually just mentioned this
in break is what happens to the guys who
are going to be draft picks in
april of 2021 when they are then told
they have to play a season right before
the nfl draft if you're trevor lawrence
are you sticking around if you're one of
these guys that's going to be a high
draft pick why would you risk it that
close to the draft when you should be at
the combine when you should be running
drills when you should be getting ready
to make millions and millions of dollars
so you're going to see a lot of high
level talent say no thank you i'm not
playing this season and from that and
then and then just like in a pure like
how are they going to figure out how to
play this in the middle of the winter in
a lot of parts of the country i don't
know mike i mean you tell me how does
this work well
because there's too much money at stake
to not make it work and if trevor
lawrence says i'm out okay clemson says
next man up and people still tune in and
watch the clemson games on tv with or
without fans in the stands right that it
still may be no favorite stands football
from from february to may but they'll
still there's too much money to not at
least try it but they can't try it until
the campuses are open again
i don't college football is the one
thing where i cannot visualize it
without fans even the nfl i can kind of
see like all right they might do this
version where it's it looks weird but
it's in a practice bubble college
football the fans are such an you know
an important part to the scene to what's
going on i just can't i can't visualize
it mike i really cannot so i think if
they wait till february they're doing
that because they can then have fans and
have the normal college football season
i think if they wait till february
they're not going to say we're waiting
till february so that we can play a
weird version of college football where
we do play in a practice bubble with no
fans i just don't see that happening
well but if that's all they can do
because we're into the third wave of the
coronavirus then that's what they will
do because they want these games on tv
and they want to make the money off of
it now does that mean every program will
do it it could be a truncated college
football season this wasn't something
fowler said this is my twist on it where
it may just be the power five
conferences and nobody else who has this
mini season just to get some of the big
man move from espn come february of next
year uh it just shows you look
the nfl can be blatant about its
desperation to play games this year
because that's what the nfl does for
college football there is
that facade that has to be maintained
that it's all part of the college
experience and they have to be very
careful on how hard they push it and
they still need that money it's going to
destroy budgets if they don't have that
money that comes from college football
and if you can't play this fall then you
play as early as you can here's the
thing i have because as it relates to
the draft i think they delay the draft
to accommodate the end of the college
football season uh because you want to
let these guys finish and you want to
play nice with college football
especially because they'd be abdicating
september through december we could have
saturday football which i know you love
every week of the year if there's no
college football think about that three
windows every saturday for 17 weeks of
nfl football to go along with the sunday
three windows mike i do love saturday
football it's called college football
but you love saturday nfl football in
december you know what i actually
thought that would be a bad move by the
nfl to to stretch it out in this case
because if you have teams playing in
front of no fans and you have games like
what happens when the nfl stretches it
out and they have bad games going on in
a prime time slot on a saturday that's
when people start complaining that's
when people stop tuning in i know
everyone always tunes into to the nfl
but you see it with the thursday night
football whenever there's a week
thursday night football game you get
that like uprising of there's too much
football and i i disagree with it but i
think that stretching it out like that
and having those solo games like last
year or maybe it was the year before
where they consciously made the decision
we're going to make sure that our prime
time games are great games and we're
going to focus on like putting out you
know the flex schedule that nbc has on
sunday nights makes it great towards the
end of the season i think if you start
stretching it out and thinning it out
and you lose that red zone and you lose
that you know witching hour on sunday
and now there's games all over the place
i think it would get a little dicey
especially if you're playing in front of
no fans in a weird hybrid football
yeah i still think that
if there's nothing else going on
and if college football is gone
it's something the nfl has to at least
consider because what else are we going
to do on saturdays you have a captive
audience
assuming that you know if we're at the
point where fans can't attend these
games then we're at a point where people
aren't going to be going out and doing a
lot of things there's going to be a lot
of people at home on saturdays i just
think it's something the nfl is going to
have to consider if those saturdays are
open from september until early december
the other thing that concerns me if you
finish a season in may of college
football how do you turn around and
start it up again late august early
september i mean these guys need some
time off so i don't know do you stagger
it for the next three or four years do
you start february of 2021 january of
2022 december of 2023 it just doesn't
make sense to me to do it that way uh
but but it just underscores
the urgency
for the people who are responsible for
college football especially at the
schools where it is a huge money maker
and the conferences where it is a huge
moneymaker to find a way
that still preserves some shred of the
ruse that these guys are student
athletes when they're clearly not and we
all know they're not and maybe they just
get to a point where they just don't
bother like let's just go ahead and
admit it all right fine we've been able
to pull this off for the last 50 years
and everyone's made a ton of money
except the players and we're now willing
to admit that yes they are just here to
play football and maybe we should pay
them some money can we just go ahead and
play college football now even if the
campuses aren't open i don't know that
that i have any high degree of
confidence that's going to happen but
maybe at some point somebody just
finally cracks mike gundy almost almost
last week cracked and admitted that
these guys are there to play football
and damn it if they're not here a lot of
people are going to lose a lot of money
not them though because they're not
getting any money anyway
i
at the end of the day i want to take a
more positive approach because i know
we're doing the doomsday and everyone's
trying to figure out what's going on why
can't like what at what point what's the
date that they have to have a hard
decision on this what's the date where
college football has to make a decision
this is where the season when the season
is going to be played
chris fowler said in making these
comments about the possibility of
february to may of 2021 he said that by
the end of may there has to be clarity
if you're going to have college campuses
open which you have to have if you're
going to bring the players back that is
about the deadline already the
university of oklahoma has said no on
campus events
through july 31 that's bumping up as
close as you possibly can to the start
of your football training camp so yeah
by the end of may which is really a long
time from now i mean here it is april
15th a month and a half
but but but but and the grand sca think
about it the last the last month and
four days since march 11 feels like it's
been a decade so what's going to happen
as it relates to the availability of
antibody testing the availability of
more widespread testing to see whether
or not people have it i think by the end
of may you do have a pretty good feel
for where this is all going to be
subject to the idea that it's all
potentially going to change i just i
don't think this is a doomsday scenario
i think that that there's a good chance
by the end of may we won't be able to
say the campuses are going to be open
and big cat do you agree with me that if
the campuses aren't open for the fall
semester you can't have the players on
campus to play football
i'm not going to agree with that
i'm not i
i i know in the ncaa i think they would
go with the greedy route of like hey we
don't care they're essential i really do
and
i really really do i think even if
i think it almost would be even better
if students were on
like at the campus because then they can
do like a quarantined bubble type of
situation where everyone is basically
separated on the team from from the you
know general student body i don't know
mike i just for me it's more like at
some point we have to have some positive
outlooks of let's just take this day by
day and hope that we can figure some
things out before the end of may like
you said which i understand could be the
deadline and it makes sense that it's a
deadline but what's happening a lot in
the media right now i saw sports
illustrated had the article where it was
like 2022 isn't gonna be until we have
sports back i don't know it just feels
like those
fear stories have sold really well when
we're talking about sports i'm not
talking about like the actual hey you
should stay inside those are good that's
good that people are taking you know the
fear and and and understanding it and
taking the precautions but in terms of
sports let's just
let's just take it i disagree i hope
they can i disagree with you
i don't think these stories sell well
these are the stories that sports fans
don't want to hear they're going to hold
their ears no
no because every sports fan every
conversation you have with any sports
fan right now the first question
am i here you're back you're back i was
making a great point too that was too
too bad i'm sure you weren't any i'm
sure you were
every single conversation that you have
right now literally i've had it a
million times when do you think sports
coming back when do you think sports are
coming back so any publication that can
basically say this is when we think
sports are coming back is going to be
clicked on a million times over and
people are going to want to know sports
illustrated had an article where it was
2022 was the first time i still clicked
on it because i was like what do they
know that i don't know everyone's
looking for answers that they don't have
that no one really has at this point
right
and i think it's fair to take the
position that we don't know and we need
to be thinking about every possible
scenario so when we do know this is what
we're talking about last hour the nfl
needs to have a plan for everything not
we plan to play we have to plan for
everything and college football needs to
plan for everything and your plans
become more crystallized once we know
what the virus is going to allow us to
do but if you have a plan for every
scenario then you do find a way to play
your games with or without fans with or
without guys in the stadiums they're in
practice bubbles with or without
everybody going to florida whatever it
may be
we will have a plan in place so we're
not rushing on the fly to come up with a
plan once we know what the virus will
let us do and that's so critical and i i
like the fact that college football is
thinking about february to may because
that tells me they are actively planning
this and i just don't know that the nfl
is actively planning to that same degree
but they should be because ultimately
the facts the reality the science are
going to drive this big cat and the
people who are responsible for those
sports we want to get back to need to
have a strategy that they can implement
effectively and quickly to go along with
whatever the virus tells us we're
allowed to do
yeah and in that point we do agree and
it is uh you know a situation where you
have to listen to the experts i just
i'm just trying to give people a
positive perspective in a time where
everyone's looking for an answer and my
positive perspective isn't even that
positive mike it's simply let's stop
trying to guess when sports come back
and let's just hope that maybe they can
come back sooner than later
right but and i don't disagree with that
but i also think that people are adults
and they understand that you can be
positive they're also realistic
but but here's where i here's why i keep
banging that drum i want the people who
are responsible for the sports to take
it deadly seriously and to have a plan
and not just have that kind of oblivious
hey it'll all be okay everything always
works out for us this will work out too
that's a recipe for disaster and my
message is mainly to the nfl have a plan
for every possible scenario because it's
going to be very hard to come up with a
plan on the fly when we get to september
or august or whenever you finally
realize where the virus is and what it's
going to allow you to do by way of
playing a season